- [Mark] Hi, Amanda.
- Hi, how you guys doing?
- [Mark] So here you are.
You are free from jail.
- [Amanda] Yeah, three months it's been.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's been three months,
now you're in a rehab.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- [Mark] Kind of on the outskirts of LA.
- Yeah, Paramount.
- [Mark] How are you liking it so far?
- It's okay.
I get cravings a lot.
- [Mark] Cravings for crack?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, I'm sure, it's not easy.
- It's not.
- [Mark] How's it gone?
- It's okay.
Sometimes I feel like leaving,
but I gotta stick it
through, I gotta stay strong.
- [Mark] Yeah, basically,
you're building a new life.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And that like
you had was so dangerous,
and so destructive.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you were gonna end up dead.
You know that, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So what's gone on in your life
in the last three months
I think is perhaps
the the way to get out of this.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Jail helped, and
that must have been difficult
to not have anything, not have
the drugs that you wanted,
and not have the freedom
that you were used to.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Was jail awful?
- Yeah, it was awful.
I was always hungry.
I gained like 30 pounds.
- [Mark] Yeah, I mean,
crack is a good diet.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- [Mark] So, I mean,
this is about the weight
you were at before, right?
Before you started using crack.
- No.
- [Mark] You were lighter, smaller?
- Definitely!
- [Mark] Oh, you were, okay.
- Yeah, I was way smaller
before I went to jail.
- [Mark] Well, you're going
through lots of adjustments now.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Lots of-
- Hopefully, I can lose the weight.
- [Mark] Yeah, I'm sure you can.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You have a new
new everything right now.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] New routine, new life.
Are you making friends here?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] There's nice people?
I mean, it's a very small rehab.
- Yeah, it's a small rehab.
It's only four people here.
- [Mark] It's very luxurious.
- Yeah, it's real nice, a mansion
- [Mark] So you have to be here, how long,
like a year, right?
- And six months.
- [Mark] Yeah, but I think a
year total just before you...
You have to be clean, I guess, for a year
before you'll be free from the
risk of going back to jail.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So what are your thoughts now?
- Nothing, I'm just staying strong.
I'm counting my days.
I want to be able to
be clean when I leave.
- [Mark] Yeah, I mean,
everybody wants that.
Lima wants it, your dad
wants it, your family.
I'd love it, the viewers would love it.
But you need to want it too.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I think that's gonna be the key.
- [Mark] And you've also been taking
all kinds of crazy medications
that probably screwed
with your diet as well.
- Yeah, the medicine made me gain weight,
that I was taking.
- [Mark] What they were
giving you in jail?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, so you're off that now?
- Yeah, I'm off that.
- [Mark] And you're doing
therapy here as well?
- Yeah, her name's Susan, my therapist.
- [Mark] Yeah, I think
that would be a great thing
for you to do some therapy
and work out whatever got
you into this situation
in the first place.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You know, I think we
never talked about your mom,
but your mom was never
really in your life, right?
- Yeah, it was hard not having a mom.
- [Mark] That would be awful.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's gotta
be a big deal for you.
- I cried a lot over it.
She did my hair once when I was
13, but I've never seen her.
She's a beautician.
She was a crack head too,
but I never knew her.
- [Mark] She's still alive, but-
- Yeah, she's still alive.
- [Mark] But she's
never been in your life.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So, I'm sure
therapy will explore that.
- Yeah, we talked about a little bit.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah, it's frustrating
not having her in my life.
- [Mark] Yeah, that'd be hard for anybody.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you're
getting your teeth fixed
next week, right?
- Yeah, I have a dental
appointment to get my teeth fixed.
Get some new teeth.
- [Mark] So how'd you lose teeth?
Your your dad and I were talking about it.
- I don't remember, I blacked out.
- [Mark] Well, he says you
got in a fight with somebody
and they knocked your teeth out.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You hit the street
or something like that.
Do you have any moments
where you're thinking
that you want to go back to that life?
- Yeah, all the time.
- [Mark] It's okay.
- Yeah, I'm trying to stay strong though.
- [Mark] Good for you.
It's gotta be...
I mean, I think crack is
probably one of the hardest drugs
to break free from.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- [Mark] And you've been
clean for three months now.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- [Mark] And I think the longer you go,
and the more you go through therapy,
and the more you get
used to this new routine,
the better your chances will be.
- [Amanda] Yeah, I gotta stay sober.
- [Mark] Yeah, you're
such a beautiful girl.
- [Amanda] Thank you.
- [Mark] And it'd be so great to see you
away from that terrible life.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- [Mark] It's such a
destructive lifestyle.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- [Mark] And you know
were you're gonna end up.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- [Mark] You're trying to
kill yourself, basically.
Do you have anything you'd
like to do with your life?
You're still young.
How old are you, you're 20?
- [Amanda] I'm 25.
- [Mark] You're 25?
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- [Mark] You're older than I thought.
What would you like to do?
Do you have any ideas?
- [Amanda] Maybe a program
where I can get a certificate,
become a technician.
- [Mark] What kind of
technician, medical, dental?
- [Amanda] Medical.
- [Mark] Medical?
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- [Mark] That'd be great.
You were going to school for something.
- [Amanda] Yeah, I just
did my basics though.
I went to school, I didn't make friends,
because I was always under my boyfriend.
He used to walk me to class.
He didn't go there.
We were just always up under each other.
So I never made friends in college.
I didn't have the college experience.
- [Mark] How did you
get introduced to crack?
Do you remember?
- Yeah, it started with primo cigarettes.
And then it leaded to crack.
- [Mark] Primos are pot
laced with the crack, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And did your
boyfriend at the time?
- No, we were broken up.
That's why I became a prostitute.
That's when I came a
prostitute, when we broke up.
I was like 22.
- [Mark] And how did prostitution
come into the picture?
- Not having money for the drug.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That'll do it.
- [Mark] So what is your
new routine here like?
I see you have a beautiful kitchen.
- Yeah, we do chores in the morning.
- [Mark] There's a pool in the back.
- Yeah, I've been in the
jacuzzi a couple of times.
It was cool.
But nothing's good as crack. (laughing)
I gotta stay strong though.
- [Mark] Good for you.
It's good that you can
talk about it though,
and admit that that's
a temptation for you.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] When is it
hardest, in the morning,
at night when you're tired?
- At night, 'cause I can't go to sleep,
'cause my lifestyle was always up.
I didn't even sleep in jail.
- [Mark] You didn't sleep
when you were in jail?
- No, 'cause I was always
up 24-seven in my lifestyle.
So it's hard going to sleep.
It's hard going to sleep.
- [Mark] What was the hardest
part of getting off of it?
The first week or the first month?
- Yeah, the first month.
- [Mark] The first month was hard?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Is it getting easier?
- No.
- [Mark] No?
- It's not getting easier.
- [Mark] It's what?
- [Mark] It's not getting easier?
- No.
It's real hard on me.
I crave the drug 24-seven.
Yeah.
- [Mark] And looking back now,
do you regret ever
getting involved in that
in the first place?
- No.
- [Mark] You don't regret it?
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah, I'll be honest.
Yeah, it's real hard on me being here.
- [Mark] Do you think if
you somehow got out of here
you'd run back to downtown
and back to Skid Row?
- No.
- [Mark] You don't think
there's a risk of that?
- No
- [Mark] Good for you.
- Yeah.
Well, I hope you can ride this out.
- All right.
- [Mark] And I think the longer you do it
the easier it'll get.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Because there is
a whole world out there
of wonderful people and wonderful things,
and wonderful things you can do.
And find something that makes you happy.
And I'd love to see you get away from that
and never go back.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I mean, look at your mom.
So your mom was using crack
and probably still is.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So that's your fate, perhaps,
if you don't do take
advantage of this opportunity.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What do you think of Lima?
- Lima's good, I love her.
She's real pretty, pretty lady.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And she's doing it really
nice thing for you too.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And your dad is
supporting you a hundred percent
and your family back in Texas.
- I definitely need support.
- [Mark] Are you getting letters
from some of the viewers?
- Yeah, I got a couple cards.
Thank you, guys!
Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, I think
there's a lot of people
that would love to see you
turn the corner on this.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
Well, all right.
- [Mark] All right, well,
I'll come back many times
and we'll do many of these,
and get updates and see how you're going.
- [Amanda] All right.
- [Mark] And you can say hi to everybody.
- Hi, everybody, thank you
so much for your support!
- [Mark] All right,
Amanda, thank you so much.
- All right.